minister
[Music]
next
[Applause]
foreign
mr president madame la minister
honorable members
last week
the european commission
after one year of negotiations
gave its green light to poland's
recovery and resilience plan
now council has to decide we just heard
it
this plan will support the polish people
on their way to a more sustainable
digital and resilient future
this is a path we've all agreed on
but the plan will do more and that's
what we are debating here today
because as in all recovering resilience
plans
there are investments linked to reforms
the approval of this plan
is linked in particular
to clear commitments by the polish
government on the independence of the
judiciary
these commitments i intended to meet the
three elements that i laid out to you
last october in the semi-cycle
and i laid them out again last week and
were so so please allow me to reiterate
them
first
the current disciplinary chamber must be
abolished
and replaced by an independent and
impartial court established by law
that means
the new disciplinary chamber must be
substantially different that's the term
the ecj has used
substantially different from the current
one
to respond to the ecj ruling
second
the disciplinary regime has to be
reformed
that means controversial disciplinary
offenses
have to be removed
for example
the request to the ecj this is no more
an offense
or the questioning of the status of
another judge this cannot be any more
offense
and third
all judges affected by the rulings of
the disciplinary chamber
shall have the right
to have their case reviewed
by the new chamber
within the clear time frame
and on the basis of the new regime
free
from inappropriate offenses
these are the three milestones
and let me be very clear
these three commitments
translated into milestones
must be fulfilled
before any payment can be made
i know that some of you are skeptical
but let me assure that no money will be
disbursed
until these reforms are undertaken the
plan is public
so a first payment will only be possible
when a new law is in force
that ticks all the boxes under this
contract
in addition poland must demonstrate by
the end of 2023
that all unlawfully dismissed judges
have been reinstated
if this is not the case there cannot be
any further disbursement
when delivered
this is progress
but we're not at the end of the road on
the rule of law in poland
agreeing to poland's recovery plan
does not stop any of the other
procedures
concerning the rule of law in poland
we will continue the ongoing
infringement proceedings
and we will not hesitate to start new
ones if needed
the rulings of the court of justice
concerning the disciplinary regime
remind remain binding
on poland
and the commission will continue to
enforce the order of the court
and apply the daily penalty payments
until the polish government complies
the milestones in our plan
our safety net to the legal procedures
of the court
honourable members as you see our
strategy is to use all the instruments
at our disposal to address all the rule
of law issues in poland
the full implementation of the
milestones
will lead to solving important issues
related to the disciplinary regime as
identified by the european court of
justice
but the rrp does not replace the
judgment it is a safety net as i said
for poland's compliance with it
when we started our negotiations with
the polish government on the recovery
plan in may one year ago
these commitments were not there
our negotiations on the next generation
eu triggered the necessary movement
now the polish parliament is debating a
new law and unlawfully dismissed judges
have a clear perspective to be
reinstated
so is everything solved
no
certainly not
but now we have movement in the right
direction and leverage
so that it leads to the results needed
and finally when i visited warsaw last
week i made it very clear
when we are talking about next
generation eu we are talking about
common european money
taxpayers money the european parliament
and member states must be certain
that this money is being spent in line
with our rules and our values
everywhere in our union
and we have given ourselves the
instruments to make sure that the
european budget is protected
both the parliament and the commission
have initiated article 7 procedures
the next generation eu regulation allows
us to push through necessary reforms
as identified in the country's specific
recommendations
this is hard work
this is a day-to-day struggle
this is our duty and i call on all of us
to work together in this challenging
time to uphold and protect the rule of
law thank you
all this president sconce